Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr and It's time for the a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Fucking Monday morning podcast that I'm just checking in on you. How's that?
Is that the worst?
Is that the worst you've ever heard? Um, Dave, no reference.
Uh, sorry. My voice is a little fucking blown out. Uh,
I did a record for episode six of the 10 that we're doing for a season two and I
don't know what the fuck I did to it. Um, who's getting new when you know,
when you lack talent,
what you try to do is you try to be loud so you can shout down all the silence.
That's what you do. You throw in a couple of f words,
a couple of fucking shit jokes. And next thing you know,
you kind of have an act, you know,
and you scraped the bottom of the fucking barrel.
That's what you dope. And when you're scraped the bottom of the barrel.
Next thing you know,
you have your party's nomination for presidency of the United States.
You know what's great about this job is I get to meet a bunch of different
people and overwhelmingly people on both sides are just going,
I don't know who the fuck I'm going to vote for. These are my, these are the,
these are the two which are supposed to decide,
added a fucking blue between these two fucking lunatics.
I don't get it. Well, I get it. What are you gonna do?
So you either vote more of the same or you step off into the abyss.
A, I swear to God,
if Trump didn't hate nonwhites as much as he seems to, uh,
or at least it wasn't so fucking out of touch,
I'd almost be excited just to see what the, what,
just just being a lazy comedian.
Just how this guy would just be fucking feeding it to you. You know what I mean?
I found Obama was kind of boring. You know, Bush was fine.
Clint was Jesus Christ. Clinton was fucking great. You know,
why don't you come over here and suck my Dick? I mean,
it was so easy to get laughs on that guy and then bullshit to just get old
after. Well, we get it. He's fucking stupid. But like Clinton,
every fucking week he was sticking cigars and people's fucking twats,
you know, he's bombing people, he's putting on weight.
He goes to McDonald's and he's got his fucking thighs out. I mean, that guy,
he was, he was, uh,
he was a comedy juggernaut because he kept changing every time you thought,
you know, all right, it's this, this, and this, and you got this guy down.
He would add another layer. Bush was just kinda hazy.
And then another fucking seven years and it's like, we get it. We get it.
He's fucking stupid. He's not stupid, but he's, I don't know.
I'll quote one of my relatives. He's not the best speaker. Um,
I don't, I barely even watched Obama Bowers over there. Oh, Ho Ho.
We just felt like he was giving me a fucking lecture. It's like, all right.
I never really found any whom I found his wife Hilarious fucking going on Ellen
and shit and tweeting, you know what I mean?
Acting like some seventh grader on Instagram. She was funny, but uh,
I don't know about him. Um, anyways,
so hopefully whatever one of the other,
I can tell you right now that both of the, either one of them,
Hillary or Trump is going to be plenty of fucking material but then instantly be
hacky. So maybe that's what it is. I don't know.
All I know is I got 'em I got, I'm doing this Wednesday night.
Um, the hockey is over.
You get so excited to see somebody win the fucking cup and then,
then there's like the next day like, oh fuck, it's over now what do I do?
Um, I'll tell you what you do. You get into Formula One.
There's another race this Sunday. The fucking,
I don't know where the hell it's gonna be. Is this the European one?
I don't know. I got them all on my phone. There's a couple in July,
then there's a as like one in August, two in September,
then like fucking every Sunday in October there's one,
then there's two more in November and then that's it. It's pretty fucking easy.
There are only a couple hours you get to watch somebody go like torn and miles
an hour. You get through to look in the crowd,
see all the people that go to the Bilderberg meetings, right?
And sacrifice people. And then you see a couple of Basque.
This is how much money's in, in,
in fucking Formula One is when you look at like the alias movie stars and like
fucking Zillionaire, you know athletes, they have a look on their face.
Like they can't even believe that they're there. They're like, wow, these,
these people have money. We thought we had money. And then,
then we came here and then we realized that we, we did, we, we, we,
we have money, but we don't have that kind of money. You know,
we don't back a fucking yacht into France.
He's fucking people back a yet into France and fucking watch a race and then
continue on. Where do they go? You know,
you ever seen those people on the yachts? Every once in a while you're like,
where the fuck? Where are they going? Do you say like you,
you cruise underneath of fucking, you got your own mountain.
Okay.
That's incredible. Um, you ever been on a boat just by yourself?
Whenever I'm on a boat by myself, I always have the same thought.
There's no fucking way I wouldn't do something illegal if I owned a boat.
There's no fucking way.
The level of freedom that you fucking have this shits you,
you're on a boat going out in the fucking ocean.
All bets are off. You get out into international waters. I mean it's fucking,
whatever you say, it becomes your law.
Literally do whatever the fuck you want to do. You're telling me right now,
if you had a fucking boat, right? Your boss was a Dick, right?
Fuck. Ah, you know, just uh, whatever.
They promoted a woman, right? Cause they had a fucking check off a box.
They guy, you are more qualified.
You came in every day with your qualified swinging Dick and junk and they had
enough of it.
They told you to stand down and then they promoted this lady, right?
You're telling me if you got a boat, right? I don't know how you got the boat.
You didn't get promoted, but whatever. This is my fucking fantasy.
Trash trashing fucking it's hypothetical lady. Right?
I know this could be considered misogynistic.
This is the woman I ran into the first 90 times.
I tried to get something on the air.
I just feel it's like this and that would be the end of my dream. Um,
but they don't have any power. Um, it's a glass ceiling. Well,
I'm running into their shoes over here is they're banging their head on the
ceiling. That was been my experience. Anyways, let's get back to the fantasy.
You're telling me if you got a fucking boat, you know,
you don't I to just, I don't know, just a kilo of cocaine.
Just for the fuck of it. Just to have the cash laying around your house.
You know what I mean? Get a Kegger, have some people over,
cook up some steaks. That's the way you do it. When you, when you're,
if you're fucking drug is just every once in awhile.
Is there a way to do that in the, in the drug game was the kid say,
can you just every once in awhile deliver a kilo so no one picks up on it,
right. You still drive your dented Prius like mate, Jesus,
my car needs a fucking bath. Like you read about.
I literally walked out of a fucking liquor store today.
It wasn't for me because I'm on the wagon.
Buddy of mine got fucking married to like bottom. Um,
it couldn't make it cause I was on the road,
so I just got them some fucking champagne shit, whatever.
And I forgot to get a card. But if on the stand I'm giving it to him,
I'll just say, hey, you know, I've got a card. He goes, dad, don't worry.
You got the booze. That's what counts. Sorry, what did he drink up? I hear Ya.
Yeah, me. I, you look at my eyes, right? I want the same boat. Oh yeah.
So anyways, um,
I came walking out of the liquor store and, uh,
I looked at my car and this thing's a fucking piece of shit,
but it isn't just on the outside, you know,
on the inside, everything's been taken care of. Right. I've,
I've maintained that thing meticulously on the outside.
It's a mess on the inside. It's beautiful, you know,
it's like an ugly person just waiting for somebody good looking to come along
and discovered that, you know, maybe they have something. I do the conversation,
you know, um, I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about,
so I'm just saying this is the way this is. If you're in,
if you're selling drugs, this is what you do it.
If he can just do it like the way Bush went to the fucking Army National Guard,
whatever the fuck he did, we just showed up every once in awhile,
you know what I mean?
Played Ping Pong dressed like a sergeant and then you just went home for like
fucking six months. That's the way you deal drugs. Alright. Yeah.
Befriended drug deal and you go, listen, this is all I want to do. I got a boat.
Okay? Every fucking Watson awhile, you know,
every whatever be fucking 18 months, you call me up, right?
You've got a key is something. Why you throw it on the fucking boat?
I'll have it on ice.
You have the coldest fucking cocaine in the universe and I'll fucking deliver it
over here, right? You break me off like fucking 15 grand. All right?
Then you just take the cash. You just got it.
You got 15 grand in cash and you don't fucking buy yourself anything.
You know, go out and buy a fucking flashy fucking car or any of that shit.
All you do, you just have it in a jar or some shit. Every once in a while.
Big Games coming up. You know, UFC event, you fucking ordering.
That's what you spend it on. You fucking blow it on your friends.
You know it's some fucking barbershop chairs in your house.
Just some stupid shit, you know? Nothing that causes that.
That's how you blow your fucking cash, man. You can keep shit on the inside,
right. You don't drive around some flashy car with the fucking elevator shoes,
whatever, whatever, whatever the kids do today. I don't,
I don't pretend to know. That's what I would do, you know?
Then every once in a while, and I don't know how to get into your bank account,
why would he do then? If you've got to pay for the UFC event,
well who gives a fuck? You pay for it out of your body. Clean money, you know?
And then all the Booz money and all the other bullshit you just take out of the
jar. There you go.
Be hilarious when you finally get caught, you know,
and you just go to trial and just be like, look, I just,
every once in a while I was like, every 18 months,
it's not even a felony a year, your honor. And you know, I just, I,
I didn't buy anything. I don't even watch this shit. I just, you know, I,
I got the NFL package and I had my friends. Oh,
everybody had their own leather chair. Yeah, we have watch shows,
the Elvis documentaries. Well, you know,
everyone's going to go horseback riding and it wasn't enough.
He bought everybody a horse and he got him a saddle,
then a little pickup truck to put the saddle in. I did that. The judge be like,
Oh, is that what your dad does? Great.
Well maybe you can take that given nature and go to jail and start giving some
hand jobs because a, see United States of America Buddy,
do you know
if you get a kilo of cocaine, right? And then you fucking
take your boat all the way out into international waters, right?
And then I meet you on another boat and then I hand you the key, uh, cocaine.
And then you give me the money in international waters and what both captains
and what we say goes and we say, uh, um, I say,
this is legal. All in favor. And we go, Aye. Aye. Aye.
Good. They don't really think, I mean,
once it's the dude who comes back in with the fucking kilo,
he's in trouble. You, once you get back within the borders,
you know what I mean? Can you sit there?
I'm really fascinated with boats now. Can you fucking just,
I don't even do drugs. This is just fascinating to me.
Can you sit in just just on the other side of international waters with a kilo
of cocaine out in the open,
just blow in stripes is the coast guards looking at you just waiting for you to
float another 40 feet over and just be sitting there. Gone on out.
I am the captain of the ship and international waters and I say this is legal.
Yeah, you probably can't do that. Right.
Cause you know what they could do is they could just come over and just say that
you were,
you were in within the borders of the U S who's gonna fucking know it's there
where it gets yours. You right there on the ocean.
There's a lot of questions I have about the ocean.
This is one of the reasons why I don't have a boat aside from the fact it's just
a fucking money pit. You know what I mean?
Can't have a boat. You can have a friend who has a boat.
That's the way to do it. Right. That's my brother always said,
you don't want a boat pill. You want, you want a friend to have a boat.
That's still, that's what it is. And then you show up, you know,
bring a little tango, rain tonic, you're a fucking hero.
And then you guide dogs to fucking boat and that's it.
He's cleaning off the barnacles. You know what I mean?
He has to explain what happened to the stores. She was here a minute ago.
I don't know. We were drinking. She must've fallen overboard.
Right then that falls you around for the rest of your fucking life.
Um, anyways, so what do you guys think?
I guess when you're listening to this, it's Thursday.
So game six in Cleveland to night to night to night.
Um, oh my God. Can you imagine if they force a fucking game seven
that would be something else. You know what I mean? Who knows?
Then you go out to fucking elites.
I'm going to give some Cleveland Cavalier fans some advice here. Okay.
God willing. They forced the game. Seven. Okay.
Cause we're all trying to avoid the dog days of fucking baseball.
You know what I mean? Nobody wants to watch that shit.
The baseball players don't want to play the games. They don't.
You only reason why they play is because if they didn't,
they wouldn't make as much money.
But nobody wants to fucking play baseball from mid June to fucking like the
second week of September. Any ball player,
if they could fast forward to all of those fucking games and just get to the
exciting part. You know who's gonna win the division? There's nothing better.
Then when it finally fucking matters after fuck a 263 regular season,
whatever they play 182 games, whatever the hell it is, 180 games.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know everybody in Chicago getting all excited about the cubs.
You know what I mean? Already rubbing one out.
They're going to bust a nut and fucking the beginning of July.
You got to pace yourself. You're not watched any pornos relax.
Cub, feds, put your shirts back on. All right?
How many fucking times if you fell for this, not saying I'm rooting against you,
but you know, slow your roll here. Cubs fans,
the level of excitement they get when you watch them every fucking year.
It's literally like watching somebody's fallen in love with his stripper,
you know, and you just sit and there like, what are you doing? You know,
you fuck them. You don't fall in love with them right now.
I'm kidding. Part of being a sports fan is the fucking misery.
And you've got to believe that's what you gotta do.
Take the kick to the seeds every fucking year and then maybe one time they
actually win it. Then you talk about that for the rest of your life. Oh,
what a year. They still live the newspaper a framed it.
Um, and then your wife throws it out. Nah, maybe she doesn't.
Maybe she's cool night. Maybe she wants us to sports too,
but then she'd probably fed, you know,
looks like you guys started putting on each other's jeans in the morning.
Just these might aff. Nothing felt weird. Yeah. Don't use that.
Usually the camel toe fit here. I guess these are yours. Um,
this has gotta be the most fucking bizarre podcast I've ever done. Um,
it's cause I'm fucking exhausted mentally from doing this shit.
Uh, I got halfway through this podcast. I'm not drinking and I was watching the,
a Jacopo story of Pistorious is that he says, name the fucking Bass player.
They're watching this documentary on him. I read the book on this guy too.
And like the beginning is all greatness.
Just once he starts going off the rails, you know,
so I kind of paused it right the right part.
If you're watching the documentary for the first hour and eight minutes,
we're actually probably about the hour and three minutes.
And then it starts to be like, oh,
and then he did this and did that and then this fucking gappiness then it's a
shit show. Um, so anyways, uh,
the fuck was I talking about, I'm talking about boats now.
I was talking about the Cavaliers now it's,
he had some advice to Cleveland Cavalier fans. Okay. God willing.
You guys force a game six. Okay. Enough for you, not for your city.
That's the offense for me. Okay. Cause I want another,
I want two more fucking games tomorrow night and I want another one. Okay.
Before I slip into, um,
the sporting abyss, you know,
and I don't give a fuck that you only have to wait another six weeks before,
you know, preseason football starts. I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck about the draft. I don't give a fuck about preseason.
I don't give a fuck about analysis.
I don't give a shit the projections.
I don't give a fuck about any of it.
Just let me know when it counts.
I am so fucking sick of watching people standing up on a fuck in front of a God
damn screen trying to explain to me what the fuck I just saw what happened and
why it happened. I don't give a shit. I get it.
You played the game and you understand it on a level beyond,
you know, just, I don't know, just fucking show who won.
Talk over the highlights and the fucking thing.
You're going to sit around and have goddamn debates. You know,
what do you think was happening in transit? Lots.
The problem with everybody knows, I don't know shit about basketball,
but I can tell you right now,
if you fucking the Cavaliers as a fucking comedian,
I know what they're doing wrong. At least they think I do.
I would think if you're up by eight points against a team that can shoot the
fucking lights out,
you'd want to throw the ball around a little bit when it was in your possession,
rather than whoever gets the ball and crosses.
Fucking mid-court just says, I'm shooting it right.
It doesn't even pass the ball. And you take like two seconds off the clock.
It's probably not what you want to do. Right? See that? I'm a comedian.
I can figure that out. Do I need four people in fucking so well,
three people in suits. Then you've got to get a lady in there, right?
She's got a fucking, she's got to run her. Yap.
She's gotta put her fucking 2 cents in. Right?
You only one of the worst fucking things ever is to be a beautiful woman,
you know, and you're with a really successful guy, you know,
and you just go around to parties and then you're just,
you just stand next to the guy going,
is he going to introduce me as they're going to introduce me. You get one time,
say hi. And then he just stand there.
The other night I did a Gig and there was this,
there was a scene afterwards and there was all these fucking, you know,
rich people with their beautiful wives and I just, I don't know,
I just started watching the wives after awhile. I don't under,
why don't they peel off and talk to each other?
It's sort of a weird thing where they just got to stand there smiling.
You can see their face hurting, you know their feet hurt from the fucking pumps.
It's fucking brutal. If you're a beautiful woman, what you should do,
you got to marry like a fucking six who just can't believe that he's with you.
Cause he'll let you go out and wear some fucking flatties some moccasins.
He doesn't,
you don't have to jack it up in the air and stand there smiling next to him.
Like one of those fucking psychos on the prices, right?
Waiting to fucking act like they're amazed about a washer and a dryer.
Get a stand next to your fucking guys wearing a sport coat trying to cover up
his fucking man tits and you've got to sit there smiling like you're happy.
You know,
putting your fucking makeup on like some clown that's probably really shot out
of a fucking candy. You don't need that shit. What are you doing?
They got to start while I tell you these fucking good looking women that marry
these really successful guys and then just stand next to him smiling, you know,
for the whole fucking evening like a stewardess at the end of a flight except
the fuck it takes four hours for the, for everybody to get off the plane.
Cause by thank you for flying. Hi.
You know whose fault that is? It's their fault.
It's their God damn fault for getting yourself into that fucking position.
Some point in the relationship. You've got to say, listen, hey mark, sit down.
We gotta talk. Guess what? Fucking Susie ain't putting on the shoes tonight.
All right, deal with it not standing next to you. Smile.
You want to go to a fucking brunch and stand next to me smiling with some after
shave on for fucking four hours. I didn't think you did. Shut up.
I'm not finished. At some point you got to have that conversation.
You know I'm not trying to be mean here. This is supposed to be empowering.
I'm saying you have the power to not just fucking stand there smiling like a God
damn. I don't know why. I don't know what it is.
You know?
I don't know. I'm talking about,
I don't even know if I saw that or I watched an episode of House of cards,
you know how's of cards? I last like three.
I lasted like three episodes and I just got sick of him fucking turn me talking
to me. It's like, dude, will you just live your life? Stop talking to me.
They're out there as the secretary of state. He doesn't know that.
I'm fucking is. Wow. Shut up. I get it. I get it.
Just stop talking. What is this,
the wonder years for adults? Um, Oh God,
I'm going to grumpy fucking mood and I love Kevin Spacey.
Why would I say these things? Why would I say these things?
Cause I'm mentally fucking exhausted and I got another eight minutes so I gotta
run my fucking Yap
running my yap on the Thursday afternoon pod cares talking about issues.
Um, what else?
I don't know that I have anything else.
I still haven't watched peaky blinders cause I'm trying not to drink and there's
no way to to watch that show and not want to fucking start.
She's pounding. Maybe I'll wait until like the 4th of July, you know,
I'll just watch. That's what I'll do.
That's a good way to spend the 4th of July.
I'll ignore my wife and just get blind drunk watching a show that she can't
understand. You know, I put on the subtitles but she,
she is just not into it. She just doesn't give a fuck. We actually had this,
we had this argument the other night. Right.
Okay.
She goes to when we go to bed, right.
She puts on the TV and she always has her shows on and what's fucking hilarious
to me.
And she's always coming at me about my temper and my yelling and flipping out,
screaming at lamps and shit or yelling at the TV or my computer. Oh,
me and my computer, if you ever heard the way I yell at my fucking computer,
you know, like that couple that just needs to fucking break up. You know,
we got in my neighborhood, dude,
I'm telling you like fucking two houses up that they've been very good lately,
you know. But I'm telling you this like times,
like you're literally like waiting to hear the gunshot.
It's like this is fucking insane. The way they scream at each other.
It's the most unhealthy fucking relationship, you know, I've ever heard.
And I gotta be honest with man, you know, sometimes I hear it and I just,
I go out on my porch and I g I just listened.
You don't let up a cigar and just enjoy it like it's a show now fucking with
yet, don't. Um, but anyways,
so she's always getting on me about my temper and shit.
You know what's fucking hilarious? Almost every fucking show she watches.
It's just a bunch of people screaming and yelling at each other.
Those reality shows that are just wall to wall clams. That's all. I mean,
you would think all these feminists out there who was sitting at trash and men
up and down, all the bad stuff we do to them. Admittedly. You know what I mean?
We make you stand next to us and smile for an entire fucking party,
you know? Oh, I'm sorry. This is my wife. Oh, I'm sorry.
This is the person that committed my life to, I'm sorry.
Did I agnostic? Did I not even acknowledge that you will fucking here?
They deal with that all fucking night. Right? All that bullshit.
I know we do that shit. But you would think that these fucking feminists, right?
You'd think that they would have issues with these fucking reality shows because
the way they depict women is, I don't give a fuck how many pairs of shoes,
how big the fucking houses, how much jewels they got hanging off of them.
They're still gonna Bitch that just fucking bitch in each other up.
She was watching one of these shows, right? And there was just like,
I don't know, 15 it seemed like there was 15 or 20 of them. So you know,
there was probably just three.
But that's the amount of noise a fucking woman can make. Right.
Three of them will sound like 15 it's like their defense mechanism because
generally speaking, they can't beat the shit out of men,
but if they just start complaining,
it just sounds like a platoon in your back down. Right.
Instead of given all three of them, I'm one of those most slaps, you know,
and all three stooges would get slapped at once. Um, anyways,
one of the episodes I saw like f, you know, like I said,
it sounded like 15 so realistically it was probably like six of them, right?
They, they went to like Rome or some shit and I'm thinking, I finally,
they got these fucking women out of this cul-de-sac now they can now they can be
excited to be in romp. They go to fucking Rome. They do the same goddamn think.
You know this bitch come up to me, started talking about,
it's like you're in Rome. You dumb fuck. Go look at something. Go eat some food.
I know it's just a show, but whatever.
She watches that shit and I'm just laying there. I hate the fucking show.
I'm trying to go to sleep and I just know she just watches these fucking shows
where they scream and yell at each other.
Now she's watching a fucking show that's about a show.
That's a show that's like that.
It's a show about a one of those reality shows like the bachelor.
You know what I mean? And I don't know. I, I don't, I W W, w, w,
w what the fuck do I know? Right? 26 minutes.
Let's read a little bit of advertising here. Why don't we do that? All right.
Type in the password.
You wouldn't want anybody to break into your computer bill with all your
secrets.
All my fucking slap fight videos that I watch.
Why don't we have a fucking password, you know?
Okay.
Yeah, I know this isn't going to work either. Anytime.
I tried to do the past with one fucking hand. You know what kills me too.
Is that one? Yeah, of course. It didn't work.
I wanted a nice simple fucking password and stupid tucked in there.
Keeps telling me that it wasn't safe
here enough. You know what? No thank you.
25 minutes. All right. Here we go. Loot crate. What the hell is this shit?
All right. Here we go. Loot crate. Everybody ever been to comic con? No.
Wish you could take it home with you. I've what? An aqua man soup.
No. [inaudible] bill. Just read the copy. Copyright it.
Have a little bit of it sent to your home every month with loot crate
packs. E three and comic con happened just once a year. All this is some fun.
This is like some mega nerd shit. All right. Yeah,
we go nerds perk up your ears. This is like when they, after the Superbowl,
when they sell like the programs and the hats and all that, I'm like,
go be to buy that done. I'm going to save it. It's going to be worth something.
Right. Um, this is for the nerds. Here we go.
Okay. So the, evidently there's something called Pax.
Evidently there's some called [inaudible] and I know about comic con and they
happen just once a year each. That's like the Grand Slam. Like you know,
in golf you got the masters, she got the British open,
the US Open and the PGA. All right. Nerds have the packs,
the three comic con and uh, I don't know,
some wonder woman thing. I don't know.
Usually that shit doesn't happen in a town near you. But with loot crate,
you experience the fun every month.
Get exclusive products from top gaming and entertainment franchise. Your,
your crate will arrive between the 20th and 25th of each month. No commitment.
Your in control partner with top brands,
you get epic exclusives in Star Wars, Nintendo,
marvel and more. Uh,
June's theme explores ways things can go wrong with dystopia,
whatever that is. Uh,
it includes the classics of Robocop Terminator Two Judgment Day and the Matrix
and new faves by I said phase bioshock infinite and fall out four.
I have no idea what any of this shit is.
You will get a figure cool collectibles and of course the dis f just stop
horrific monthly t what does it mean?
An action figure. Go to Luke,
crate.com/burn enter my code birth deadline is the 19th at 9:00 PM to subscribe
and receive this month's crate. When the cutoff happens, that's it. Game over.
For less than $20 a month, you get six to eight items.
That includes license gear, a pair of collectibles and unique,
one of a kind items. This is an over $45 value. Luke,
crate.com/burr and enter my code Barbie you to save $3 off any new
subscriptions. Um,
I did a Gig the other night where there was like professional gamers there and
stuff. They make all this fucking money. It's like the greatest thing ever.
You play video games for a living, you know,
that's what this country has become. It's become like your turn your hobby.
Like me, I turned fucking around telling jokes in a warehouse into a career.
Skype plays video games, you know what I mean? You like Robyn one out,
you get into porn. God knows we don't manufacture anything.
And there's like two things left in this country, a growing weed and,
and fucking, uh,
starting like a nonprofit. You know what I mean?
Most of those are bullshit anyways, right? We got to help people. Uh,
we got to pinkies. There's a bunch of paint, you know,
Pavin two pinkies affects most people. A lot of people don't even talk about it,
you know,
all they do is just make it sound like it's a bad thing and then you all of a
sudden you're just giving them money. That was probably a bad example,
but you know what I mean? All right. Boll and branch, everybody.
The branch as you set out to improve yourself.
There is one simple thing you can do every day to help you be your best in every
situation. That's getting a good night's sleep. A fucking ma'am.
I can tell you four days sober. I forgot what it's like to wake up and be like,
you know what? I want some eggs. Whoa.
A bullet branch was the rest you need wrapped up in there.
Super comfortable luxury linens and they do it right there.
The first Benny Company to be fair trade certified,
which made your sheets come from the work.
Hap work up happy hands and not from sweatshops and beautiful package sheet
packaging made entirely from recycled and sustainable materials.
I wish more more companies did this. Um, all right.
You can only get their sheets in one plates place.
That's Boll and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality,
not department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go to bowl.
That's B o l l and branch.com and they'll let you try them out risk-free for 30
nights. If you don't like them, send them back roast.
You have nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to bowling and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets, towels,
blankets, and do VA covers everything.
Plus free shipping in all their products come beautifully packaged and this
signature boxes go to boll and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order
and use the Promo Code burr bullet,
branch.com Promo Coper Boll and branch.com po a Promo code burn.
All right, day you go. What time is it? How much time did I do?
Oh, 32 minutes. Oh, that was fucking painless. Wonderful. All right.
Hey everybody. I'm heading back these tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow, tomorrow.
I'm heading out and I got a,
I'm playing in New Jersey at the New Jersey Pack Center,
Performance Arts Center, whatever the fuck you call it.
Then I'm down in Atlantic city on Saturday and then on Sunday
I'm playing some goddamn place. Alright.
All of the dates are available on bill bird.com. Guess what, everybody?
The uh, the fucking Belfast tickets are already on sale.
I'm doing two shows out there and I think Dublin guests who the openers gonna be
a, when I say Joey, you say Rose's. Joey.
Yeah. Joe De Rosa. Joe De Rosa. Where this,
um,
Dan something and there's something I was supposed to read some all think comedy
thing to, where the fuck is this day? Where is it?
Hang on a second. Hang on a second. I'll. Thanks. Come here we go.
Here we go. Weekly tweet. All right. All right. You know what?
I'm not going to tweet about this. I'll talk about it.
A Yanas Papa's one of the funniest motherfuckers coming up.
All his characters and all this standup has a new debut album called,
let me be honest. You get it instead of let me be honest.
Let me be honest. There's a Greek son of a bitch, a,
it's available today on all things. Comedy records.
I got a tweet about this.
I was supposed to do this five fucking days ago when an asshole.
I'm gonna tweet about that right now. All right.
This has been the Thursday afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday boarding podcast and ah, just checked in on you. Uh,
be a little music here and then we'll play
a half hour is shit for a podcast a long time ago.
Maybe a little bit of time ago, but, uh, it's not going to be this one. Alright.
Kahn's have a great weekend.
[inaudible]
phone farther from Joe's
[inaudible] phone faster.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's
going on? It's a bill burr. It's some Monday morning podcast.
Um, what is it? One 48, one 49. There we go.
Just change west coast time. And, uh, I'm in a great fucking mood.
I'm not in the God damn airport. You know
why I always say, you know, like you're gonna fucking talk back to me.
I'm, no, I haven't great mood. I'm actually in my apartment laying in my bed,
chilling the fuck out and uh,
I'm in a great mood. Even though I had a, uh, I had a fucked up week.
Really? Bill, you had a fucked up week. Why is that? Well,
I'm going to tell you, um,
I've been making jokes over the last four months about me.
I'm driving a dented hybrid and talking about how emasculating that is.
You know,
it's like already I'm driving a hybrid so I had to deal with everybody.
Go and do what do you effect? You know what I mean?
Suggesting that because I'm making the air a little bit cleaner that for some
reason that on some level that means I want to suck a dick, which is a,
it's very childish yet affective, yet effective.
It's very hard in a group situation. One on one maybe can defend it,
but in a group situation when somebody yells out, what are you effect?
What ends up happening is that even guys who won in the social circle will start
laughing and then it's like,
you know you're fucked because people are laughing at the question of what are
you saying? Like, if you suck Dick or whatever, you know,
if you to start talking about, you know, how
you know,
how you're thinking about the environment that actually digs the hole deeper,
you know, and the people like, well maybe, yeah, look at him.
He's talking about the environment.
Only people who are into the same sex, uh, are into the environment.
They know. It's funny actually about the hybrid is when I bought it a year ago,
I got a ton of shit for it.
People made fun of the little tires and everything else, you know,
but as gas prices have crept up,
I feel like four 60 to four 70 out here in lost Congolese.
Um, all of a sudden people are now coming up to me being like, so what's, uh,
what's the deal with those cars? But they, uh, you know,
and then they asked the usual dumb questions like, can they go up a hill?
No, no, they can't. Fortunately,
everywhere I want to go involves driving on a perfectly level surface,
if not a little bit downhill.
And then I take the long way around and somehow I get back without having to go
back up the hill. That just fucking drove down.
It would've it sell it Goddamn car that doesn't go up the hill. You know,
ask me that question. It was my mother. My mom asked me that.
You went on a hybrid
[inaudible] Hell No. Mom. I moved to Nebraska,
moved to Nebraska. That's what I did. And it's funny,
there's no hills in Nebraska, but there are tornadoes.
Okay. Um, okay. This is what happened.
20 20th I drive around this fucking Dennett car. Oh, if you new to my page,
this is the Monday morning podcast and I do one of these every single week.
You know, people ask me questions, uh,
people send me information and uh, whatever.
And I babble about my life while I hype upcoming gigs, like a,
the fact that I'm going to be doing stand up on the guys' choice awards this
Sunday night,
June 22nd on spike TV guys, choice awards.
I believe it comes on somewhere between eight at night and four in the morning.
No, I think it's 10 o'clock. I don't know when the fuck it is.
If I was organized, I know that, but I did six minutes to stand up that they,
I believe are going to whittle down to three minutes. And uh,
I had a great time and they were a bunch of famous people there and I was
jumping up and down like a girl scout inside, outside. I was playing it cool.
Like, hey there a person who I've always admired. How are you? Yes.
Nice to meet you too. And instead of like, Oh God,
I can't believe I just shook their head. And they said, nice job. You're funny.
It was a thrill. I had a great fucking time. Um,
so I got that coming up. Oh,
also this week I'm going to be at the punchline in Atlanta.
One of my favorite clubs. See little, a great mood on it.
What's the last week's podcast? That was not a good mood.
That was me in an airport wanting to get the fuck out of there. Oh.
And by the way, for those weekly listeners of my podcast, you know,
I was going from Raleigh trying to get back to la because it's fucking Raleigh.
There's no direct flight.
I had to fly from Raleigh up to Cleveland and then from Cleveland to fucking La.
Well, uh, my connecting my Raleigh to Cleveland,
the flight was late because wind, if you remember. And when I,
by the time I got to Cleveland, my flight to La had already left.
So I'd have spent five fucking hours and the God damn Cleveland fucking airport
we with, with, with, what was the, they gave me,
they give me a $15 voucher to spend five hours in that fucking airport.
And I was, uh, I did my usual, I flipped out a little bit. I was like 50 dude.
And The lady's like, well, you know, I actually hooked you up. They usually, uh,
I gave you the dinner voucher. The lunchtime voucher is only eight.
You know,
that's one of those times you just want to reach out and cross and just grab
someone by the throat, even though they didn't make the rule.
Just to make you feel better and be like, bitch,
you're not giving me fucking eat those fitness fucking airport for eight hours.
All right, I want,
I want one fucking 30 bucks and I want free Internet. That's what I want. Okay.
I don't want some $50 voucher, so I go get a chicken sandwich with mushrooms.
Oh Shit. Was that good? God Damn. And I had a good chicken sandwich in there.
It all worked out. So anyways, this, this is uh,
this is what happened this week. So anyways, so I've been driving around this,
uh, my, uh, my hybrid, there was dented,
it got dented initially cause some douchebag backed into me and I got that fixed
immediately and then the next time it got dented it was cause my girlfriend,
uh, yeah, I dunno, she misspoke in a parking way,
put it that way and she fucking, I dunno what she did,
but it came home and it looked like fucking big foot had a pair of timberlands
on and stomp the Goddamn quarter panel. So I've been driving around with that.
Right. Was scrape marks on the side. It just, it just, you know,
as a man, you don't want to have a car with a dentist.
It just makes you feel like a fucking loser.
Forget about the fact that it's a hybrid and it has those little fucking search
roll up size tires. Okay.
So I finally get the thing fixed after four months,
you know, cause I want to make sure she learned how to parallel park, you know,
for, she fucked the thing up again. So that's taken care of.
So I get the Goddamn thing fixed. This is how excited I am.
Fight. My girl comes to pick me up at the airport as I'm hugging her, right?
Like World War II ended.
I'm looking over her shoulder looking to see that there's no dent in the car.
And you know what I mean?
It's almost like I was cheating on her in like an automotive kind of way.
So I was excited. The fucking thing looked great. Everything was fantastic.
And I drove this car. Tell us on Monday,
Thursday I go over my management's office.
I valet the fucking thing, one of those deals where, you know,
I valet it but I park it cause there's a spot right there. I go to my lunch,
I come back from lunch and there's a fucking dent in my car again.
The exact same spot, the exact same side.
So now it's the bumper and I swear to God,
I never understood the expression I was beside myself.
I never knew what the fuck that meant. But when in that moment I get it,
it's some sort of out of body experience where I was just,
I had to look at my driver's license.
So my license plate like seven times. I was like, there's no fucking way.
That's my car is his campy, my car. And I didn't,
it just kept looking down and it was with my fucking card.
So then I look over at the valets,
okay mind you within the exact same spot and they're not looking at me.
This is all shit I put together afterwards. But I was so flustered.
I came up there and I was like, well the what happened to my car?
I felt good voice went up like nine August. Oh, he's even mad.
I was literally like, uh, I felt like I was going to fake.
Let me see those old movies where they got some broad and you know,
they get their,
those dresses down to the floor that has like 52 layers of underwear underneath
them. That's why I should've had all of those,
a fucking hoop skirt and I should have just fainted with one of those little
umbrellas that you spin around and it doesn't really keep the rain or the sun
off you. It's just supposed to make you look more attractive.
I should've been holding one of those and that's what I shouldn't,
that's how flustered I was.
So the fucking parking attendants are like, I'm like, well,
you know what happened? Like car and they would just like, oh yeah. And all day,
uh, somebody, uh, somebody hit hit it, somebody hit, I might,
who hit it. I don't know that they,
we backed it over there and somebody hit it and fucking did that that day.
You know, everybody, every fucking word sounded like it started with a date.
You know, so, um, I'm like,
I can't fucking believe it.
And then they gave me the sheet of paper to fill out, you know, right there.
They should have told me that they fucking did it because if someone else hit
me, first of all, if you saw the fucking dent in this car,
there's no way these guys didn't hear it, you know?
And they just automatically give me this form saying that they,
I guess they're going to pay for it. So I'm filling the shit out.
And it wasn't until I drove away that I started thinking about it.
I had pulled over and I'm looking at the dent and it's the exact same shape as
the polls in the garage.
So obviously one of those fuckers
drove it into a pole and then after they drove and into a pole,
they stuck it back in the space where I, where I have left it
and then tried to fucking,
then they would look and down and I'm making eye contact.
I think they were trying to hope that I didn't see it. Do you want to help?
One of those fucking guys is one of my listeners every week. All right, dude,
why don't you just fucking come clean and let me know you did it. Okay. I know.
Like, cause you don't want to get fired, right? Is that what it is?
I just can't fucking believe it, man. I just,
it's so God damn depressing my fucking car. It's got another God. Damn.
I just got to fix four days. I drove around for four days.
I don't understand it. You know what I mean?
It's not like when my car didn't have a dent in it,
I started driving around and making fun of people who had dents in their cars.
So there was some sort of fucking calmer going on.
Why didn't deserve to not have a dented fucking car? So,
so that's it. Now it's unreal, man.
I can't have a car, doesn't have a fucking [inaudible]. And uh,
I really wish I didn't tell this story because I started off in a great mood.
And as you can tell by my tone, I'm not in such a great mood anymore.
It's just really fucking, man. I'll tell you what's extra frustrating.
They give me this piece of paper or some lady's on it and they're like, yeah,
yeah, she doesn't call you in the next five days. Give me a call.
And like I said, I was so beside myself. I said, okay.
And it wasn't until day three I was like, wait a minute,
somebody doesn't call me in the next five days.
How about the next five fucking minutes? Fucking idiot. You ruined my car.
Or this phantom lady ruined it.
And then you got in it in it for some fucking reason to put it back in the same
spot. You five put two inch fucking jackass.
I just, Ah, maybe that's why he put it.
Then it gave his c over the fucking steering wheel.
I listened back to last week's podcast and I just really felt like,
I sounded like I was too, God damn upset on it and it was too depressing.
So I tried to start this one off and try to stay focused in a good mood and then
look what happened for them.
Had 13 minutes in and I'm already flipping out again. I just, you know,
anybody else?
Anybody else got any fucking stories out there like that they can make me feel
better. Maybe I could read to some of the listeners. I'm like,
I want to hear some of your,
I fixed my car or I just bought a brand new car and then some fucking contacts.
Jesus. No, no, no. I'm dropping the seabird. All right, let, let's,
let's get back to my dates here. Okay. Um, so that's the deal.
I have a dental hybrid. Again, you know, let's think of some positive shit.
The Celtics won one game, like they had two out in la,
one of the greatest comebacks ever. And uh,
they get to one Boston that's hopefully gonna win it.
I actually went to game three, Celtics lost that one,
but I was still on some to go to the, uh, go to the finals,
but I gotta admit man or the referees were, uh, they were little,
they were crazy.
The amount of foul that was the game right after Phil Jackson was complaining.
Remember that game too when they called 56 files on the Lakers and like three on
the Celtics don't eat, bitched about it. And I think the referees get pissed.
But kind of knew we was right. So they,
they were like calling a ton on the Celtics,
but they also kind of go and fuck you Phil Jackson, we're still running shit.
So they still called a bunch on the Lakers and I don't think the ball went up
and down the court three times without them blowing the whistle.
Like there was never any sort of like slow to the game and it kind of sucked as
a fan because they kept cock blocking the excitement.
Even when the Lakers were going on and run, you know, even as a self extends,
sitting there was pretty, you know,
it was cool to see them going bananas and feeling like I was at a finals.
But every time they'd start to go nuts, they'd call some ticky tech file.
And then the other way when they would start getting quiet and I'd start
standing up talking shit, they, they call another bullshit once.
So I don't, I don't know what the fuck they're doing,
but in the last night's game, I thought the officiating was really weird.
It was like the beginning of the game. Like, all right,
they going to let him play.
They will let them mug each other and then all of a sudden they start calling.
They just picky tech. It's not consistent that I'm inconsistent. Plus we lost.
So I'm probably a little cunty too. Um, but anyways, uh, here we go.
Punchline in Atlanta this week, uh,
from June 19th to the 21st.
This is one of my favorite gigs and I absolutely loved going to that club.
It's just an old school club. If you live anywhere near there, please come down.
I've got a brand new hour and I also have a solution to the, uh,
the gas problem. I really do something that would be effective, uh,
very effective. If, uh, did I say effective, very effective, effective
within eat. Now we're going a ASTEC did like it. Uh, you know what,
that's one of those things, I never know the difference, the effect or effect.
I might have to look that up. Um, all right.
And then July I'm going to be at the Improv and put spark from, uh,
July 10th through 13th. Then, uh,
the next Gig I have and after that is July 31st through August the fuck is it?
Hang on. Hang on. The pages, there's going to be at the comedy works.
That's what it is. The comedy works in Denver, Colorado from August. I mean,
July 31st or 30th.
I already turned the page for less fucking day in July through, uh,
Saturday, August 2nd. Nice. No Sunday. Gotta love that. Yeah.
There's 31 days in July. 31 days have November,
except for September and Friday. Honestly,
I want to go. All right. Um, do I have anything else? The Heights.
I think that's pretty much it. Uh, podcast questions.
All of a sudden, nobody's asked me podcast questions.
Is that what happened last two weeks?
I didn't answer any questions to now you guys, you can't ask me any.
I got a question for you. Where the fuck are all the questions? Are you over it?
Um, I don't know what. Okay. I think it's time to wrap this fucking thing up.
What the hell was I just looking up? Oh, effect
aspect.
I'm trying to teach you guys something effect and effect you like how I don't
know the difference and I'm going to act like I'm teaching you.
Which of these sentences are correct.
Rising oil prices will have an effect on nearly everyone.
That's correct. With any right.
Why don't you just give me the fucking definition. I hate when they do this.
Their emotional outbreak first was purely for effect.
You know, wait a minute. All of these sentences correctly.
Employee effect and effect. And in most situations we use effect as a noun,
an effect as a verb. Well, what the fuck do they mean?
How about giving me a definition first? You know what? This is like,
this is like how they, I was taught Algebra, you know what I mean?
Like everything would math up until eighth grade for me anyways,
was numbers. If you fucking Asian,
I'm sure you were doing calculus in the third grade,
but let's just stick with your random fucking stupid American here. All right.
[inaudible] right up to eighth grade. It was all fucking numbers.
Then all of a sudden ninth grade comes around and they throw the fucking
alphabet in there and there was no sort of, before they go in, you know,
little little speech like, Hey, this is going to be a little different.
The dude just started doing it. He just started throwing, you know,
foil first outside, inside last, uh, you know, the, all that,
all that high school math opposite angles are congruent and none of his shit may
, and you just, you just repeated it like you were in a cult.
They just stand up. They opposite angles are congruent.
Opposite angles are congruent.
Nobody had any idea what the fuck they was and they just had a triangle on the
board. That's what this website is like.
Get it right online.com. Uh,
there's no fucking definition.
All of these flyers correctly. Webster's code, this fucking thing.
All right. Hey, is this exciting? Is this an exciting podcast?
As I attempt to fucking look up God damn word and fail miserably.
Affect effect.
Cause you guys do this shit at work and death admission. You know,
you try to look up like Robbie Knievel and try to guess what year he's here.
He was born. All right, here we go.
Affect definition of effect
to have an influence or effect or a change in,
you know what? Fuck this word. Okay, forget it. You know what I mean?
That's like the difference between a truck and a car and the definition of car.
They describe it as a fucking truck. You know what?
Sometimes you got to cut your losses and you got to realize that you're not
going to know some things in life. So that's just one of them, you know?
All right, what does this podcast,
this is just been spam for the last three minutes. I apologize. Um, you know,
I just had to eat. You know what?
I should actually turn this into a contest and say I'm going to give out,
give you a free 100 DVDs. If you could guess what the fuck I just ate,
cause you'll never guess what it was. Think of the most, okay.
I'm going to give you a hint and you can all play along at home.
All right? This is something, it's a dessert.
It's a something that they used to have creepy commercials about with a high
pitch voice and you put it in the freezer.
Three answer in two. One,
I actually just had a slice of cookie posts.
There's no way to say that without fucking laughing.
I just had a piece of cookie Puss, ice cream cake,
whatever the fuck you call it. It's ice cream and cake. Just like effect and,
and effect. They're the same thing. Fucking incestuous.
And you, I gotta tell you something. If you've never had it,
it's just as disgusting as it sounds. You know what I mean?
Some things are just named perfectly and cookie posts. It just what it is.
It says,
stank rank slutty ass fucking disgusting cake.
Like if, if, uh, who's the right whore to pick up?
It's gonna say a Paris Hilton was a cake. She wouldn't be,
she'd be like a fucking blow pop. Sorry. Uh, I don't fucking know.
All right, whatever. My sugar levels up to the fucking roof.
Why do I have up God damn fucking ice cream cake?
Cause I turned 40 last Tuesday on gym on Sunday.
That's the way I was dying. I rejoined, I'm like fuck this.
I turned 40 on Tuesday. Let me let me bang out 500 setups.
The last 500 steps to being 39 years old.
Um Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty fucking brutal.
But I'll tell you something and somebody shows up. You know you have a party,
a place and somebody shows up with a cookie posts,
ice cream and you know it's not that bad. Not because you eat it,
it tastes good. You're more thinking like, well you know, maybe I,
if I was addicted to sweets I'd eat, eaten his fucking horse shit every day.
All right. Did we learn anything this week? Yes we did.
We're going to learn that bill burns is going to be on the fucking, the a,
that's like guy's choice awards this Sunday at a,
somewhere between eight and 4:00 AM on Spike TV and a,
I am going to be at the punch line in Atlanta and a, I don't know,
the definition of effect and effect and a cookie puss.
Ice Cream tastes like a tastes like Eskimo.
Uh, yeah, you went down on a fucking Eskimo hooker.
It's really fucking, it's, it's just, it's fucking awful.
Let me see if I can just, first of all, some Carville,
it's got a big green fucking ice cream nose with a Conan.
And I just can't imagine like you ever see those people that are so fat that
like fucking bedridden. This is the kind of shit that they eat.
Cause you know, everybody's out of shape. I'm fucking out of shape right now.
You know what I mean? Everybody wants, you get tests dirty.
You got a fucking gun. Nobody looks good without this shirt on.
It's everybody stopped whining on that fucking biggest loser. Okay.
No one looks good to put your client. Okay. But, uh,
those people who get so big that they're just fucking dead written,
you really have to go out of your way.
You have to go above and fucking beyond to get that big,
you know what I mean? They were [inaudible] slow metabolism.
Fuck you and your fucking metabolism. No, you don't.
You are eating cookie posts nightly, nightly basis.
I had just had a snack. What you have,
I had cookie plus all fucking 3000 fucking calories a slice.
Damn. We kill them. That's how I like to fucking end it.
I like to attack the bedridden and that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast app. Please, uh, re up with the questions.
I swear to God, I'll read them.
I will answer them next week and somebody please give me a fucking definition
the difference between effect and effect, because, you know, I, I, you know,
I looked it up and they use the definition of the other word and the fucking
definition, which is annoying. All right. Um, that is it. Uh,
thanks. Everybody came up to me to see my show in Raleigh, North Carolina.
It's the most disjointed fucking podcast ever. Um,
did I use that word correctly? Um,
in Raleigh and I'm Caroline's, um,
I'm adding a bunch of new dates coming up.
I got a date coming up with the stress factor in New Jersey. Uh,
I got to college, Umass Amherst.
I'm going to be adding that date shortly. Uh, what else? What else?
I Dunno. Sometime in August, the beginning of September.
So look for those dates and anything else.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com and, um, and that's it. All right.
I'm tapping out. I'm talking to that next week after week. Correct.
Too much walking shoes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].